حملة قصف أخرى تقودها الولايات المتحدة في اليمن،
إنها على الأقل الجولة الثالثة من
الضربات الأمريكية لتفكيك
المسلحين الحوثيين المدججين بالسلاح والمدعومين من إيران أثناء مهاجمتهم
العدوانية للسفن التجارية في
البحر الأحمر، وذلك في الوقت الذي أعلنت فيه القيادة المركزية
الأمريكية أن البحرية الأمريكية استولت على
صناعة إيرانية.  صواريخ باليستية كانت متجهة إلى
المسلحين الحوثيين في اليمن الأسبوع الماضي
بينما كانت العملية المعقدة للبحرية أه كومب
ناجحة في أخذ
الأسلحة التي كان من الممكن استخدامها على الأرجح
لاستهداف السفن التجارية في
البحر الأحمر، وانتهت بخروج اثنين من قوات البحرية
إلى البحر بسبب أمواج هائجة تبلغ 8 درجات
تقول البحرية إن هذين البحارين
لم يتم العثور عليهما بعد ينضمان إلينا الآن،
وزير الدفاع في عهد دونالد ترامب
مارك إسبر أه، شكرًا جزيلاً لوجودك
هنا، فلنبدأ بهذه
الضربات الجوية الأمريكية الأخيرة على الحوثيين واليمن، لماذا
تتباعد هذه الهجمات  ما
تفعله الإدارة الآن وليس مجرد
قصف جميع معاقل الهوي
مرة واحدة، هل هناك استراتيجية لذلك جيدًا؟
لا أعرف بالضبط ما
هي استراتيجيتهم أو ما هي استراتيجيتهم ولكن بالطبع نحاول
تحقيق الردع وأفترض أنهم
أعطوا  لقد
أصابوا أكثر من 60 هدفًا
في ليلة واحدة، حيث اعتقدوا أن ذلك
سيكون كافيًا لردع المزيد من الضرائب،
ولم يحدث ذلك حتى الآن، وكان من المهم
ملاحظة أنه في الأسبوع الماضي عندما تم
إجراء الضرائب، قامت وزارة الدفاع  قال إن الأمر يتعلق
بإضعاف وتعطيل أه
قدرتهم على شن الهجمات التي أعتقد أنه
ربما تم تحقيقها ولكن يبدو
أن الحوثيين سيستمرون
في هذا حتى نستمر في تدمير
مواقع الرادار الخاصة بهم وتدمير
منصات الإطلاق الخاصة بهم أعتقد أننا يجب أن نذهب  بعد
قيادتهم وسيطرتهم سيرسل ذلك
رسالة أقوى حول
جديتنا أيضًا وبالعودة إلى استيلاء الولايات المتحدة على
هذه الأسلحة الإيرانية الصنع،
هذه الصواريخ الباليستية متجهة إلى
الدقائق القليلة الماضية،
يبدو أنها كانت مهمة معقدة
أه  الأول من نوعه منذ أن
بدأت هجمات الحوثيين على السفن في الخريف، كم هو
كبير تأثير الاستيلاء على مثل هذا
ماك في قدرة الحوثيين على استهداف
السفن في البحر الأحمر نعم حسنًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء
قلوبنا أه أفكارنا وصلواتنا
تخرج  بالنسبة لقوات البحرية وعائلاتهم
الذين ليسوا كذلك الآن، فأنت تعلم أننا
ما زلنا نبحث عنهم ولكن انظر إلى أنها
مهمات معقدة، وأعتقد أن
أهمية ذلك تكمن في أننا نحاول القضاء
على سلسلة توريد إيان من أجل أه
الحوثيين أه لديهم بضع سنوات حتى الآن
لبناء قدراتهم أه
طبيعة العملية تشير أيضا إلى
أن هذه الأسلحة
تأتي من إيران إيران
تزودها مثل حزب
الله حماس الشيعي  الجماعات في
العراق وسوريا سمها ما شئت، لذا مرة أخرى
يعود الأمر إلى إيران ومن المهم
أن نفعل هذه الأشياء وغيرها التي
نحتاجها لقطع خطوط الإمداد التي
لا تذهب إلى الحوثيين فحسب، بل إلى
حماس أيضًا